street tv on c-span 3
75 years ago in january 1945 the soviet
army liberated auschwitz the largest
nazi death camp in november of that year
war crimes trials began in nuremberg
germany and the us army signal corps
fill many hours of the trials for
posterity
next on real america a u.s army
documentary of the nuremberg trials
first screened in germany in november
1948
using nazi and allied films documents
and testimony nuremberg chronicles the
rise of nazi germany its annexation of
neighboring countries military invasions
war crimes and death camps
this version has english language
narration recorded over the trial sound
and contains many scenes of war and
death that some viewers may find
disturbing
[Music]
so
[Music]
it was 1945
the war was over
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
painfully life
came back to the ruins of europe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the war was over
but there was no peace
despair crouched over the continent
hopelessness circled europe like a bird
of prey
why
what were the forces
what were the issues in a war that
turned nations into rubble heaps
and populations into beggars
the people wanted the answers they
wanted to know what happened and why
in the palace of justice in nuremberg
the people of the world came together
for there sat the international military
tribunal
to judge the chief nazi war criminals
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
just as robert h jackson the chief
american prosecutor
makes the opening statement for the
prosecution
the privilege of opening the first trial
in history for crimes against the peace
of the world
imposes a grave responsibility
the wrongs which we seek to condemn and
punish have been so calculated so
malignant and so devastating that
civilization cannot tolerate their being
ignored
because it cannot survive their being
repeated
that four great nations
flushed with victory and stung with
injury
stay the hand of vengeance and
voluntarily submit their captive enemies
to the judgment of the law
is one of the most significant tributes
that power has ever paid to reason
this inquest represents the practical
effort of four of the most mighty of
nations
with the support of 15 more
to utilize international law to meet the
greatest menace of our times aggressive
war
the common sense of mankind demands that
law shall not stop with the punishment
of petty crimes by little people
it must also reach men who possess
themselves of great power and who make
deliberate and concerted use of it to
set in motion evils which leave no home
in the world untouched
in the prisoner's docks at 20 odd broken
men
reproached by the humiliation of those
they have led
almost as bitterly as by the desolation
of those they have attacked
their personal capacity for evil is
forever past
merely as individuals their fate is of
little consequence to the world
what makes this inquest significant is
that these prisoners represent sinister
influences that will lurk in the world
long after their bodies have returned to
dust
they are living symbols of the arrogance
and cruelty of power
of racial hatreds
of terrorism and violence
they are symbols of fierce nationalisms
and of militarism
of intrigue
and war making
which have embroiled europe generation
after generation
crushing its manhood destroying its
homes and impoverishing its life
they have so identified themselves with
the philosophies they conceived and with
the forces they directed
that any tenderness to them is a victory
and an encouragement to all the evils
which are attached to their names
what these men stand for
we will patiently and temperately
disclose
we will give you undeniable proof of
incredible events the catalog of crimes
will omit nothing
it may be that these men of troubled
conscience do not regard at trial as a
favor
but they do have a fair opportunity to
defend themselves
a favor which they rarely extended to
their fellow countrymen
we will not ask you to convict these men
on the testimony of their foes
there is no count of the indictment that
cannot be proved by books and records
and we will show you the defendant's own
films
you will see their own conduct and hear
their own voices as they reenact for you
from the screen some of the events in
the course of the conspiracy
the acts of the defendants have bathed
the world in blood
and set civilization back a century
they have subjected their european
neighbors to every spoliation and
deprivation
they have brought the german people to
the lowest ebb of wretchedness
they have stirred hatreds and incited
domestic violence on every continent
these are the things that stand in the
dark shoulder to shoulder with these
prisoners the real complaining party at
your bar
is civilization
the united states of america present
count one of the indictment
that all the defendants participated as
organizers or accomplices in a common
plan or conspiracy to commit crimes
against peace war crimes and crimes
against humanity
the aims of this conspiracy
were open and notorious aims of this
conspiracy were open and notorious it
was far different from any other
conspiracy ever unfolded before a court
of justice
pistol shots
and then
wildfire the heart left this old boy
experiences where he lives
its history
is the history of the nazi party
which grew from the brawling streets of
munich in the 20s
and from the beginning adolf hitler and
his followers were committed to the use
of any means
whether or not they were legal or
honorable
their aim was the highest degree of
control over the german community
their intentions were blatantly put
forth in mein kampf and the party
program
[Music]
and they preached their favorite
doctrine up and down the land
they said that persons of a so-called
german blood
were a master race entitled to subjugate
or even exterminate other races they
said that the german should be ruled
under the fear of principle or
leadership principle by which each
sub-leader owed unconditional obedience
to his superior and so on right up to
adolf hitler
they said that war was a noble and
necessary activity of germans
and they said that the nazi party alone
had the right to rule germany
and the right to destroy the party's
enemies
[Music]
their rise to power was based on fraud
deceit
intimidation and coercion
culminating finally
in terror and flame
[Applause]
into that flame
went the democratic constitution of the
weimar republic
and the freedom of the german people
[Music]
for the fires set by the nazis
extended to the very reichstag
hans gazavious
a witness who formerly held a high
position in the berlin police
administration
[Applause]
first of all we ascertain that quite
generally hitler had stated the wish for
a large-scale propaganda campaign
gerbils took on the job of making the
necessary proposals
and it was gerbils who first thought of
setting the rice stuck on fire
a group of ten reliable as a man was
made ready and now going was informed
about every detail of the plan
it was expected from guring and he gave
his assurances that he would do so
that the police would be instructed
while still suffering from shock to take
up a false trail
using the rice tug fire as a pretext for
seizing power
the nazi conspirators lost no time
in tearing germany away from a policy of
peace
late in 1933
they led their nation out of the
disarmament conference
quipped the league of nations
and embarked on a course of secret
rearmament
by 1934
the new armaments program designed by
defendants gerring shark and funk
was going full blast
[Music]
german industry was again turning out
the tools of war
the crooked plants hummed
and one year later gerring could
announce
from the strong foundation of the
national socialist ideology
today rises once again the german armed
forces
a few days later general von blumberg
announced the new law for compulsory
military service
[Music]
the law was signed by defendants guri
hess
frank
prick
shark and fonura
the training began
[Music]
finally
in spring of 1936
the nazis sent their new troops
[Music]
soldiers of the army which was created
by order of the fewer
crossed the sacred river of german
history and occupied their former
garrisons
they pledged
whatever decisions he may make
unbreakable faith and obedience
and they vowed to follow him and to
prove their sincerity by their
never-ending love for germany
the columns grew longer
[Music]
the sound of boots grew louder on the
streets of nuremberg
but hitler said
german people is not a people which
welcomes the war today tomorrow or the
day after tomorrow
our country are
they want to perform their work
but the nazi conspirators in the name of
laban's realm continued to plot new
aggressions against peace
in november 1937 hitler called a special
meeting with defendants goring for
neurot and raider
and generals from bloomberg and funfritz
the meeting was secret but lieutenant
colonel husbach hitler's personal
adjutant faithfully recorded hitler's
words
the german question can be solved only
by way of force
for the improvement of our military
political position
it must be our first aim in every case
of entanglement by war to conquer
czechoslovakia and austria
simultaneously
the annexation of the two states to
germany militarily and politically
would constitute a considerable relief
this meeting set the stage for nazi
expansion
and act one came only three months later
at berchtesgaden where defendant fund
poppin finally engineered a meeting
between shushnig the austrian chancellor
and hitler and defendants caitel and fun
riven trump greedo schmidt who was
austrian foreign minister at the time
also attended the meeting
and now he takes the witness stand did
hitler demand that seis inquired be made
minister of security that was one of the
demands on that program were there also
demands made with regard to currency
exchange and customs
there by demands of an economic nature
of every kind
hitler told you that you had until
february 15th to accept his terms didn't
he
and he told you that if you didn't do so
he would use force
the ultimatum as hitler stated it was
that he intended as early as february to
march into austria and that for the last
time he was prepared to postpone it
faced by these threats the austrians
carried out all hitler's demands
[Music]
but the nazi conspirators weren't
satisfied
a month later when shushnig announced a
plebiscite on austrian independence
hitler and defendant goring demanded the
plebiscite be cancelled
another ultimatum demanded shushnig
resign within three hours
fearing invasion
churchnig resigned and finally defendant
seis inquart was appointed the new
chancellor of austria
that same day gerring in berlin
called kepler of the german embassy in
vienna
the conversation was transcribed
kepler spoke first
well we represent the government now
yes that's it you're the government
listen carefully the following telegram
should be sent here from size include
take the notes
the provisional austrian government
sends to the german government the
urgent request to support it in its task
to help prevent bloodshed for this
purpose it asks the german government to
send german troops as soon as possible
well as a and s are marching through the
streets everything has collapsed with
the professional groups science import
is the only one who still has power in
austria yes then our troops will cross
the border today
[Music]
the act was written
joining austria to germany and signed by
defendants seismark
curry prick
juan riventrop and hess
hitler of course had said
germany neither intends nor wishes to
interfere in the internal affairs of
austria to next austria or to conclude
an angelus 21st of may 1935 out of
hitler
[Applause]
[Music]
the curtain fell on act one but already
the nazi conspirators prepared for act
two
with this 1938 memorandum from hitler to
his high command
it is my unalterable decision to smash
czechoslovakia by military action in the
near future
it is the job of the political leaders
to bring about the politically and
militarily suitable moment
conrad henline was designated political
leader the plan was labeled operation
green and defendant yodel issued another
memorandum reading operation groom will
be set in motion by means of an incident
in czechoslovakia which will give
germany provocation for military
intervention the fixing of the exact
time for this incident is of the utmost
importance
a few months later
germany signed the munich pact with
england france
and italy
this pact involved the transfer of the
sudetenland to germany
the conspirators called it their last
territorial demand
but before the ink was dry they were
making other plans
for hitler's goal was the complete
absorption of czechoslovakia
and now the czech president hasha was
called to a meeting with hitler and
defendants gerring from riventrup and
kaitlyn
they gave him the ultimatum bohemia and
moravia would be incorporated into
germany immediately
or czechoslovakia would be invaded and
prague destroyed from the air
parker was helpless
defendants from ribentrop and frick
signed the decree making bohemia and
moravia a german protectorate
speaking some months before about the
sudetenland however
hitler had said
i have promised and repeated here that
there will be no more territorial
problems for germany and europe
i will be no longer interested in the
czech state and i will guarantee it 26
september 1938 out of hitler
[Music]
now according to more of his adjutant's
notes
hitler reviewed the nazi plan of
violence and treachery from 1934 to 39.
the notes read first rearmament in 1935
the introduction of compulsory military
service after that militarization of the
rhineland one year later austria came it
brought about a considerable
reinforcement of the reich the next step
was bohemian moravia then followed the
erection of the protectorate and with
that the basis for action against poland
was laid
basically i did not organize the armed
forces in order not to strike the
decision to strike was always in me
in the name of the united kingdom of
great britain and northern ireland sir
hartley shawcross presents count two
crimes against peace
charging that all the defendants
participated in the planning and waging
of wars of aggression wars in violation
of international treaties agreements and
assurances
the first step was the rhineland and the
next step
the rhineland is occupied austria and
czechoslovakia are seized by germany
and now the nazi conspirators turn to
the next problem the conquest of poland
again an adjutant lieutenant colonel
schmunt transcribed hitler's words the
solution of the problem demands courage
it is impossible without invasion of
foreign states or attacks on foreign
property
there's therefore no question of sparing
poland and we are left with the decision
to attack poland at the first suitable
opportunity
we cannot expect the repetition of the
czech affair
there will be war
meanwhile according to their
well-established practice the
conspirators stirred up the dancing
issue to furnish frontier incidents
which could justify an attack on poland
then on 23 august the nazis signed their
non-aggression pact with russia
then hitler told his high command
now poland is in the position in which i
want her
i'm only afraid that at the last moment
some schweiner will make a proposal for
mediation
appeals were made twice by the pope
and by president roosevelt
[Music]
finally mr roosevelt asks that assurance
be given him that the german armed
forces will not attack and above all not
invade the territory or possessions of
the following independent nations
he then names as those coming into
question finland
let them
return iceland robbing
green denmark new zealand
hospital ireland palka portugal spain is
on one september 1939 the nazis sent the
vermont smashing into poland
and into a new world war
for france and england faithful to their
mutual assistance pact with poland
immediately declared war on germany
the luftwaffe
opened mass attacks on polish towns and
cities
[Music]
and hitler according to schmutz notes
said destruction of poland in the
foreground
i shall give a propagandist cause
starting the war never mind whether it
be plausible or not
have no pity take a brutal attitude
but as usual before the attack on poland
hitler told the world
during the troubled months of the past
year the friendship between poland and
germany has been one of the reassuring
factors in the political life of europe
30th of january 1939
the path of destruction started in
poland but soon it led north and south
across all europe
and each new aggression was based on
hitler's principle that in war victory
not right
is what matters
non-aggression treaty it is firmly
resolved to maintain peace between
denmark and germany in all circumstance
31st may 1939 ribbon drop
but on 9 april 1940
german troops invaded denmark
[Music]
[Music]
the german rice government is determined
in view of the friendly relations which
exist between norway and germany
under no circumstances to prejudice the
inviolability and integrity of the
norwegian state
2nd of september 1939 purchase life
but on 9 april 1940
german troops invaded norway
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i assure the governments of belgium
holland and luxembourg that germany will
not violate their neutrality 6th of
october 1939
[Music]
but on may 10 1940
german troops invaded belgium holland
and luxembourg
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the firmly established reliable
relationship of germany to yugoslavia
will represent an element of calm to our
nerve-wrecked continent
this piece is the goal of all who are
disposed to perform really constructive
work first of june 1939
but on 6 april 1941
german troops invaded yugoslavia
[Music]
[Music]
these criminal methods of the nazi
conspirators brought them early success
and by 1941 they had most of europe
under their heels
now an evil ambition for power and more
power drove them on
but two of the world's mightiest nations
the united states and soviet russia
remained to block the nazi drive for
world supremacy
they had to be dealt with firmly
immediately and now germany asked for
cooperation from her full partner in
aggression to the east
and from her junior partner to the south
in berlin they drew up the axis pact the
blueprint of the new order and parceled
out the continents of the world for axis
domination
italy was to get the mediterranean
sphere
japan was to get the orient
and to germany would go the rest of the
world
[Music]
in june 1941
in violation of their non-aggression
pact the nazis sent the wehrmacht deep
into soviet territory according to
military plans long made
as usual there was no declaration of war
hitler had said today germany tomorrow
the world
and this was tomorrow
[Music]
land warfare in the east
air warfare in the west
for now defendant gerring's luftwaffe
was hurled with full force against the
people and cities of britain hitler
after all had told the reichstag
i will blot out their cities
[Music]
[Music]
and then on 7 december 1941
the japanese
keeping their end of an infamous bargain
struck at the united states
also without declaration of war
japanese bombs reigned on pearl harbor
spreading war finally to the pacific
[Music]
the new order was on the march world war
ii flamed around the globe
in the name of the union of soviet
socialist republics
general rudenko presents counts three
and four
charging that all the defendants
committed war crimes in germany and in
all those countries occupied by germany
the nazi conspirators committed crimes
against enemy armies against prisoners
of war
against the civilians of occupied lands
they believed in the barbaric doctrine
of total war and considered themselves
freed from the restraints of
international law
or the established customs of war
their ruthless policies were ordered in
directives like this one from general
reiniket of the vermont high command the
bolshevist soldier has lost all claim to
treatment as an honorable opponent
active or passive resistance must be
broken immediately by force of arms
prisoners of war attempting to escape
are to be fired on without previous
challenge
no warning shot must be fired
more proof of this savage nazi policy
comes from the affidavit of court lindau
former gestapo officer they existed in
the prison of war camps on the eastern
front small screening teams headed by
lower ranking members of the gestapo
it was the duty of these teams to
segregate the prisoners of war who were
candidates for execution according to
the orders that had been given and to
report them to the office of the gestapo
and a letter from defendant rosenberg to
defendant keitel in 1942 stated clearly
a large part of the soviet prisoners of
war has starved or died because of the
hazards of the weather
in many cases prisoners of war could no
longer keep up on the march because of
hunger and exhaustion
in numerous camps no shelter for the
prisoners was provided at all
even tools were not made available to
dig holes or caves
[Music]
yet when some objected that this
treatment violated the geneva convention
defendant kaidel answered with this
memorandum we are concerned with the
destruction of an ideology therefore i
approve and back the measures
this is proved by the testimony of
general lahouzen who worked under
admiral canaris in the op fair
general lahouzen attended conferences
where crimes against whole populations
were plotted in advance
by the nazi conspirators
will you please explain exactly what
took place at this conference in the
furore's train
first of all
had a short talk with von ribentrop
particularly as regards the polish
region
secondly canary spoke vehemently against
the measures that t canaris had found
out about to wit
the projected shooting and extermination
measures that were being directed
against the polish intelligentsia
nobility and clergy as well as all
elements that could be regarded as
embodiments of the national resistance
movement
[Music]
[Music]
canara said at the time more or less
verbatim that the world will at some
time make the armed forces under whose
eyes these events have occurred also
responsible for these events
defendant frank nazi governor of poland
was another of the conspirators guilty
of directing mass murder
in his diary he speaks of
taking advantage of the focus of
attention on the western front by
carrying out wholesale liquidation of
thousands of poles
these atrocities were not restricted to
the east
here is the proof in the village of
auradur sergeland france
[Music]
here is the proof
[Music]
in the town of bond belgium
[Music]
[Music]
here is the proof
in the san callisto caves italy
where 350 hostages were carefully listed
[Music]
and systematically murdered
and here is
in czechoslovakia
in blind retaliation for the
assassination of ss man heydrich
the nazis murdered all leticia's men
and sent their women and children into
slavery in germany
but this was not enough
boys of the arbeit stings were moved
into the ruins of leadership and ordered
to level the village to the ground
[Music]
[Music]
leadership was to be the nazis example
to all occupied peoples
[Music]
but more terrible still were the
concentration camps which from the
beginning had been the conspirators
chief weapon against opposition of every
kind
german anti-nazis were the first victims
but with the war their numbers swelled
to include citizens of all the nations
of europe
their fate is described by witness
rudolph hearst
i commanded auschwitz until the 1st of
december 1943 and estimate that at least
two and a half million victims were
executed and exterminated there by
gassing and burning
at least another half million succumbed
to starvation and disease making a total
debt of about three million
included among the executed and burned
were approximately twenty thousand
russian prisoners of war were delivered
at auschwitz and vermont transports
the remainder of the total number
included about a hundred thousand german
jews
and great numbers of citizens from
holland
france
belgium
poland
hungary
czechoslovakia
greece and other countries
[Music]
medical experiments too were standard
procedure at many concentration camps
these included lowering the body
temperature to 28 degrees centigrade
high altitude tests and pressure
chambers
experiments with poisoned bullets and
contagious diseases
and even sterilization experiments
this was genocide
the premeditated destruction of entire
peoples
genocide the direct result of the nazis
claim that they had the right to destroy
the party's opposition
tomorrow the world
dead or alive
[Music]
in the name of the french republic
monsieur de monton closes counts three
and four
the final charges of the indictment
all the defendants committed crimes
against humanity
including the murder and persecution of
all people opposed to the nazi party
and the enslavement exploitation and
deportation of civilian populations
the slave labor policy was the
responsibility of defendant sokol who
admitted in 1944
out of the 5 million workers who arrived
in germany not even 200 000 came
voluntarily
forced labor often meant brutal and
degrading treatment for circle himself
suggested
all the men must be fed sheltered and
treated in such a way as to exploit them
to the highest possible extent at the
lowest possible expenditure
and defendant bormann added
the slavs are to work for us
and so far as we do not need them they
may die
slavery was only one aspect of nazi
exploitation
defendant going in a talk with german
occupation authorities in 1942
discussed another
plunder
god knows you are not sent out to work
for the welfare of the people in your
charge but to get the utmost out of them
so that the german people can live
this everlasting concern about foreign
people must cease now once and for ever
i have here before me reports and what
you are expected to deliver it makes no
difference to me in this case if you say
that your people will starve
but nazi crimes against humanity were
not limited to foreign peoples
defendant frick
as minister of interior directed a
program aimed at aged
insane or incurable germans
the so-called useless eaters thousands
were committed to special institutions
fuel ever returned
evidence proves they were murdered
because they were useless to the plans
of the nazi conspirators
[Music]
but perhaps the greatest crime against
humanity the nazis committed against the
jews
a campaign of hate and murder that goes
to the heart of the nazi movement
[Music]
[Music]
uh
is
[Music]
german citizens are only those of german
or related blood willing to serve the
german right and people
marriages between jews and citizens of
german or related blood are prohibited
[Music]
so
[Music]
ss brigadier general stroup
in charge of the warsaw ghetto in 1943
had learned his nazi lessons well in a
secret report he said
the reichsfield ss ordered on the 23rd
of april 1943 the cleaning out of the
ghetto with utter ruthlessness
i therefore decided to destroy and burn
down the entire ghetto
jews frequently left the hideouts but
occasionally remained in the burning
buildings and jumped out of the windows
only when the heat became unbearable
[Music]
life in the sewers was not pleasant
after the first week
tear gas bombs were thrown into the
manholes and the jews were driven out
and captured
countless numbers of jews were
liquidated in sewers and bunkers through
blasting
the longer the resistance continued the
tougher became the members of the
weapons s police and verma who always
discharged their duties in an
accidentary manner
little by little the nazis were reaching
what they called the final solution the
total extermination of the jews of
europe pers described the process well
we had two ss doctors on duty at
auschwitz to examine the incoming
transports of prisoners the prisoners
would be marched past one of the doctors
who would make spot decisions as they
walked by
those who were fit for work were sent
into the camp others were sent
immediately to the extermination plan
children of tender years were invariably
exterminated since by reasons of their
youth they were unable to work
[Music]
we endeavored to fool them into thinking
they were to go through the lousing
process
[Music]
it took from three to fifteen minutes to
kill the people in the death chamber
depending upon climatic conditions
we knew when the people were dead
because their screaming stopped
[Music]
we usually waited about one half hour
before we opened the doors and removed
the bodies
after the bodies were removed our
special commanders took off the rings
and extracted the gold from the teeth of
the corpses
much of this loot was then transferred
to secret vaults of the reichsbunk at
frankfurt on mine
the reichsbunk of defendant funk
[Music]
labor chief robert lye
knew that six million jews died in the
nazi's final solution
in his will he said
in anti-semitism we violated the basic
commandment of god's creation
it is hard to admit mistakes but the
whole existence of our people is in
question
we must have the courage to rid
ourselves of anti-semitism
god has taught me that in my cell and
knowing that
[Music]
and defendant frank himself said
[Music]
which are terrible a thousand years will
pass and this guilt of germany will
still not be erased
the prosecution rests
the defense begins
they call 61 witnesses and introduce 38
000 affidavits on the defendant's behalf
they submit 136 000 more affidavits on
behalf of ess 10 000 on behalf of the sa
7 000 on behalf of esd
3000 on behalf of the general staff and
okw
2 000 on behalf of the gestapo
these attorneys were personally selected
by the defendants
many are well known german lawyers and
each now rises to plead acquittal for
his client
some make blanket denials of all guilt
some of the defendants had without doubt
a great influence in those fears which
did not interest hitler they had no part
whatsoever in the great decisions
concerning war and peace
armistice and peace offers etc
other attorneys lead their clients
through a carefully prepared defense
here striker is examined
foreign
it has also been stated by the
prosecution that himmler and carlton
broner would have had no one to carry
out their orders to kill if you hadn't
made that propaganda and if you hadn't
conducted the education of the german
people in that sense
i don't believe that those who had been
given the order by the fuhrer to carry
out the killings or to pass an order to
kill
that those people would have been made
to do this by my periodical
hitler's book my kampf existed
and the contents of that book were the
authority the cause
next comes carlton brunner
[Music]
you are accused of establishing mouth
housing of inspecting and visiting this
camp regularly
the witness her regal testified having
seen you in this camp and further
testified having seen you at the
inspection of gas chambers and while
these gas chambers were in operation
[Music]
every concentration camp on the right
which i know anything was established by
himmler through paul
later the prosecution is allowed to
cross-examine the defendants
rosenberg is questioned
did your ministry force people to leave
their homes to go to germany to work for
the german state
and it is not denied that some terrible
encroachments occurred
now
radar takes the stand
on the 23rd of may in the reich's
chancellery hitler said that he would
give you an indoctrination on the
political situation and he said
we are left with a decision to attack
poland at the first opportunity
did you still think that he had no
aggressive intentions
i believed that for a long time
justice general yodel said after hitler
had solved the check problem purely
politically it was to be hoped he would
also be able to solve the polish
question without bloodshed
i believe that until the last moment
until the 22nd of august
title is cross-examined
yesterday your council showed you this
order dated 16 september 1941
it said that it is necessary to take
immediate cruel measures and that human
life in the east is absolutely worthless
you remember the basic idea of the order
that human life costs absolutely nothing
please answer the question
you signed this order with this
statement
[Music]
next yodel
do you remember any other reason for
such great mortality among soviet
prisoners of war
but they seem to be completely wrong
that i do know
now one ribbon drop
are you telling the tribunal on your
oath that you knew nothing about the
effect of military pressure on austria
i wish to stress again that i knew
nothing about military measures and that
if i had known something i wouldn't see
any reason not to say so
but it is a fact that during the days
before and after the hitler meeting i
was so busy taking over the foreign
office that i could give only slight
attention to the austrian problem
[Music]
then guring is cross-examined
at the end of the meeting you used the
following words didn't you
german jewelry must as a penalty forfeit
one billion marks
then the pigs won't commit any more
crimes
do you still say that neither hitler nor
you knew of the policy to exterminate
the jews
i already have said that not even
approximately did i know to what degree
this thing took place
you did not know to what degree but you
knew there was a policy that aimed at
the liquidation of the jews
i only knew that certain perpetrations
had taken place
spare takes the stand
you were present on april 23 1945 when
hitler received the telegram from goring
suggesting that he take over power
what did hitler say on that occasion
[Music]
hitler was most excited about the
contents of the telegram and he
expressed himself in a very clear manner
about guri
he said that he knew for some time that
goering had failed that he was corrupt
that he was a drug addict
it was typical of hitler's attitude
toward the entire problem however that
he followed this statement up by saying
but he can nevertheless negotiate the
capitulation
he stated in an offhand manner
it doesn't really matter who does it
his disregard for the german nation was
expressed in the way he said this
after months of examination and
cross-examination several defendants
make final statements to the tribunal
frank is first
speaking from the very depth of my
sentiments and from the experience of
five months of this trial i want to say
this
now that i have gained the last insight
into all that which has been committed
in the way of dreadful atrocities
i feel a terrible guilt within me
funk declares
when these measures of terror and
violence against jews were put up to me
i suffered a nervous breakdown because
at the moment it came to my mind with
full clearness that from here on the
catastrophe took its course all the way
up to the terrible and atrocious things
but which we have heard about which i
knew only in part at the time of my
imprisonment
i felt ashamed and guilty at that moment
and i feel the same way today
but it's too late
now
speaks
words
it is my guilt that i educate a german
youth for a man who committed murders
million-fold
is next
everything he promised to the german
people and thereby to himself he did not
afterwards keep
he promised equal rights for all
citizens
and without regard to their capabilities
his adherents got privileges before all
other citizens
he promised to fight against political
lies and together with his minister
girls and by himself he never did
anything but disemanate political lies
and political fraud
he released criminals and put them into
his service he did everything in a way
of not keeping his promises he deceived
the world
germany and me
spare once more
the tremendous danger contained in this
totalitarian system
only became really clear the moment we
were approaching the end
everything that has happened during this
trial everything you have seen in the
way of orders which were carried out
without any hesitation
that after all turn out to be mistaken
that is why this trial must contribute
to the prevention of such distorted wars
in the future
and to the establishment of principles
for human cooperation
and cuddle again
of the causes of the disastrous methods
and the terrible consequences of this
war that will arise for the german
people a new hope for a better future in
the community of nations
[Music]
to abandon this way which was doomed to
failure and the will and justice of god
and which is doomed for everyone who may
try to follow it anywhere in the world
the last defendant to speak is friction
see
did not expect anything good from hitler
and you are amazed about the extent of
what really happened
but then try to understand the
indignation of those who did expect
something good from hitler and were
betrayed
am one of these betrayed
finally
both defense and prosecution sum up
their arguments for the tribunal
an aggressor can be branded only by the
world's conscience that supreme organ of
humanity must have not only real but
also moral authority its impartial
judgment must be looked upon with
general confidence it must stand above
the contesting parties
in the name of the united states of
america justice jackson delivers his
summation
according to the testimony of each
defendant
these men saw no evil spoke done and
none was uttered in their presence
if we combine only the stories from the
front bench
this is the ridiculous composite picture
of hitler's government that
emerges
it was composed of
a number two man who never suspected the
jewish extermination program
although he signed over a score of
anti-semitic decrees
a number three man who was merely an
innocent middleman
transmitting hitler's orders without
even reading them
like a postman or delivery boy
[Music]
a foreign minister who knew little of
foreign affairs and nothing of foreign
policy
[Music]
a field marshal who issued orders to the
armed forces but had no idea of the
results they would have in practice
a security chief who was of the
impression that the policing functions
of his gestapo and sd
were somewhat on the lines of directing
traffic
a party philosopher who had no idea of
the violence which his philosophy was
inciting in the 20th century
a governor general of poland who reigned
but did not rule
[Music]
a gal lighter of franconia whose
occupation was to pour forth filthy
writings about the jews but who had no
idea that anybody would read them
a minister of the interior who knew not
even what went on in his own office
much less the interior of his own
department and nothing at all about the
interior of germany
a reichsbank president who is totally
ignorant of what went in and out of the
vaults of his bank
[Music]
to say of these men that they are not
guilty it would be as true to say there
has been no war there are no slain
there has been no crime
[Music]
in the name of the united kingdom of
great britain and northern ireland sir
hartley shaw cross delivers his
summation
this trial must form a milestone in the
history of civilization
not only marking that right shall in the
end triumph over evil
but also that ordinary people of the
world and i make no distinction here
between friend and foe
are now determined that the individual
must transcend the state
the state and law are made for man that
through them he may achieve a fuller
life
a higher purpose and a greater dignity
in the name of the union of soviet
socialist republics general rudenko
delivers his summation
and when we ask have the charges against
the defendants been proved before the
court
have the defendants been convicted of
their guilt
there is only one answer
their crimes have been proved
neither the statements of the defendants
nor the arguments of the defense were
able to refute our grave accusations
it has been impossible to cast doubt on
events which actually took place
the truth cannot be challenged
that is the real meaning of this trial
that is the lasting result of our long
and strenuous effort
in the name of the french republic mr
dereb delivers his summation
when this international trial is closed
and the principal war criminals
sentenced we shall go back to our own
countries
the fate of these men now lies entirely
with your conscience
this is beyond our competence
our task is finished
now it is for you in the silence of your
deliberations
to listen to innocent blood crying for
justice
[Music]
lord justice lawrence great britain
mr francis biddle united states
museu de faber france
and major general nikitchenko ussr and
their alternates prepare the verdict
it will be based on the opinion of the
majority
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on october 1st 1946 the verdict is
delivered by lord justice lawrence
president of the tribunal
[Music]
of the organizations
the ss
sd
gestapo and leadership corps are found
guilty the high command
s a and reich cabinet not guilty as for
the individual
wilhelm hermann goering
guilty of conspiracy crimes against
peace
war crimes and crimes against humanity
death by hanging
[Music]
rudolph hess
guilty of conspiracy and crimes against
peace
life imprisonment
joachim von riventrop
guilty of conspiracy crimes against
peace
war crimes and crimes against humanity
death by hanging
wilhelm keitel
guilty of conspiracy
crimes against peace
war crimes and crimes against humanity
death by hanging
[Music]
ernst kaltenbrunner
guilty of war crimes and crimes against
humanity
death by hanging
alfred rosenberg
guilty of conspiracy crimes against
peace war crimes and crimes against
humanity
death by hanging
hans frank
guilty of war crimes and crimes against
humanity
death by hanging
wilhelm frick
guilty of crimes against peace
war crimes and crimes against humanity
death by hanging
julius streicher
guilty of crimes against humanity
death by hanging
walter funk
guilty of crimes against peace
war crimes and crimes against humanity
life imprisonment
kalmar shocked not guilty on this
indictment released
carl dernitz
guilty of crimes against peace
and war crimes
ten years imprisonment
eric reider guilty of conspiracy
crimes against peace
and war crime life imprisonment
baldur funshira
guilty of crimes against humanity
20 years imprisonment
[Music]
guilty of war crimes and crimes against
humanity
death by hanging
alfred yodel
guilty of conspiracy crimes against
peace
war crimes and crimes against humanity
death by hanging
france von papen
not guilty on this indictment
released
albert spare
guilty of war crimes and crimes against
humanity
twenty years imprisonment
constantine for noira
guilty of conspiracy crimes against
peace
war crimes and crimes against humanity
15 years imprisonment
[Music]
arthur seis
inquad guilty of crimes against peace
war crimes and crimes against humanity
death by hanging
[Music]
hans fritsche
not guilty on this indictment released
martin bormann tried in absentia
guilty of war crimes and crimes against
humanity
death by hanging
the trial is over
[Music]
seven begin their prison sentences
goring
chooses to die by his own hand
the other 10 wait for the gallows
[Music]
in nuremberg
the people of the world found out
and why
[Music]
but nuremberg is more than an answer to
a question
as justice jackson said
this trial is part of the great effort
to make the peace more secure
[Music]
it constitutes juridical action of a
kind to ensure that those who start a
war
will pay for it personally
nuremberg stands as a warning
to all those who plan and wage
aggressive war
[Music]
you can watch archival films on public
affairs in their entirety on our weekly
series real america
saturday at 10 p.m and sunday at 4 p.m
eastern here on american history tv